[Music]
welcome to the cherry spoiler show
i'm your host paul aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man
and this video are breaking down the
ending of cherry directed by the russo
brothers
the tom holland movie has a lot to
unpack from it and throughout this video
we're going to be going over its story
ending and our thoughts on it full
spoilers ahead so if you haven't had a
chance to check out the film then i
recommend that you check out now
make my day have a cherry on top by
smashing the thumbs up button
and also subscribe for videos like this
every week without the way thank you for
clicking this
now let's get into cherry okay so cherry
is somewhat of a twisted love story that
centers around addiction and breaking a
toxic cycle
the film is actually based on the
autobiographical story of the same name
by nico walker
and this documented many of his highs
and lows because of the narration
and life story elements within the film
i sort of view it as a cross between
forrest gump and requiem for a dream
it's getting a lot of mixed reviews and
one of the biggest criticisms i've seen
lobbied against it is that tom holland
is completely miscast as a bank robber
personally i kind of think that's the
point and you aren't really supposed to
see this guy as a believable threat
instead i took the movie as portraying
how even a good kid can end up doing bad
things
if he's placed on certain paths with the
wrong sorts of people
walker stated that the title cherry
refers to the phrase pop the cherry
and though this is normally used in a
way that refers to losing your virginity
the author said it's meant to be more of
a reference to a transition in life
nico goes through several of these
transformations and whether it's him
being a student
joining the army or becoming a criminal
at several points in the film a red
title screen is used to show how he's
gone from one state to another
holland to me gives a great performance
and i really respect that he is an actor
is taking on challenging roles
instead of just sticking to comic book
movies even though he does shoot his web
fluid at one point however
that doesn't mean i don't think that the
movie doesn't have any faults
i did struggle to see what nico sees in
emily who is pretty much the love of his
life
she's basically the jenny in this story
and is rather cold
even to the point that when nico tells
her he loves her she just says thank you
spooked by this admission she says she
wants to go to school in canada
basically ending their relationship and
thus nico decides to enlist in the army
she does eventually admit that she loves
him but by this point it's too late to
stop him from heading out
now this is the first moment in the
movie where nico is presented with a
choice
and rather than making the right one he
makes the wrong one
made a medic nico is sent to iraq where
he sees
firsthand that the training he's
received is pretty useless
and nothing he does is any help to
anyone i feel like this movie is very
anti-army
and at one point it even portrays them
as just kids playing war games
they even alter the aspect ratio so it
feels like an old school television show
rather than something that's actually
happening and because of this
it's difficult to take the life and
death experiences that they're being
trained for seriously
nico is clearly rocked by the experience
and after the trauma he faces firsthand
in the field
he develops mental health issues which
lead to him seeking out help in america
prescribed oxycontin by a man named
doctor whomever
nico ends up going onto hardest stuff
from here he and emily end up on a
downward spiral when both become
addicted
and they enable one another they end up
being put in charge of guarding a safe
which they smash open and after pushing
and flushing most of the contents
they become indebted to a big dealer
named black in order to pay him back and
continue their addiction
nico begins to rob banks and after
facing no real resistance
he becomes a career criminal now the
film ends with nico realizing that
things are gonna get worse and worse as
long as he's with emily
at this point getting high isn't just
something they do
it's very much a cornerstone of their
relationship and when she overdoses her
mother asks nico to leave her alone
i think it's at this point that nico
realizes that they're gonna constantly
be in the cycle of committing crimes
in order to fuel their addictions this
will put the woman that he loves in more
danger
and thus he has two options either
continue on this path
or remove himself from the situation he
tries to put emily on a bus
but she refuses and this cements to him
that as long as the pair have their
addictions
the relationship will continue to be
toxic though he loves him more than
anything
i think nico realizes that he's not
someone who's responsible enough to
control his actions
and that he and emily will always end up
back together unless he forces a way for
them to be apart until they get clean
nico says goodbye to emily and heads to
a bank to commit his final robbery
which is where he tells the teller to
sound the alarm he heads out and hands
the last of the money that he owes over
to black
and fires a gun in the middle of the
street in order to draw attention to
himself
after injecting for the last time he
waits for the police to arrive
and is then sent to prison now this is
actually
how the book itself ends the real nico
wrote it in prison
and therefore didn't really get to add
the events that we see play out in the
movie
after serving his time and growing a
mustache nico leaves prison
fiddling with his wedding ring in a move
that is similar to what we saw in iraq
with a soldier trying to get the blood
to come out of his
some of that soldier nico was away from
the one that he loved
and he viewed the ring very much as the
symbol of their bond
even though they were apart this is
something that kept him going through
his time in prison
and the character was clearly desperate
to see emily again
emily going to canada and him going to
iraq were both things that kept them
apart from each other
and it allowed the pair to figure out
what they wanted but the trauma he faced
eventually led to more prison on the
other hand enabled him to get sober
and being away from emily it also
allowed her to do the same thing
nico became somewhat of a star prisoner
and after serving years to the point
that tom holland actually went through
puberty
he was released on parole my bad tom
yeah you know i love you you know
you know what over here yeah now the
film ends with the pair both free of
their addiction
with nico's focus on emily rather than
his trauma
we cut to the title against the red
background that shows another transition
in his life
and this cements that going forward he's
gonna be a different person
now one of the big questions hanging
over the film is who shot coke
the character ends up fleeing during the
middle of a robbery
and when we next see him he's been
fatally injured
i have watched the scene several times
to figure out exactly how this happened
and there are two moments in which i
think things went down upon fleeing the
bank with nico we can hear what sounds
like gunshots
and at no point during this is nico ever
fired at
when they're in the car nico also says
he hears something
which because of the cut in the scene is
likely a gunshot
and due to the police driving off at
this moment i believe it could have
happened during this
it's difficult to tell exactly what
moment this was
but those two are probably the most
likely
now before we get into our review i just
want to let you know we're giving away a
marvel 4k box set of your choice to
three subscribers on the 31st of march
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the film
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter heavy
spoilers
okay so what did i think of the movie
well as i mentioned it's getting mixed
reviews
and i think i sort of fall in the middle
of that
i don't think this is absolutely
terrible like some people are saying
but i also don't think that it has a lot
of special moments in it
in iraq i felt the movies pacing
severely suffered
and because of the budget it was
difficult to believe that they were in
any combat situations
the pacing was completely off at this
point and i thought it was really
difficult to fully connect with the
characters in the absence of emily who
is very much the person that cherry
focuses around
and why i say that is because though
nico is the main character
all of his actions and what he does tend
to be in service of her
therefore when she's removed it's
difficult to stay engaged with the story
as we know that he will have to return
to her before any more major
developments occur
they could have cut about 20 minutes out
of the phone without losing anything
and i feel like this plotting does bog
the film down a bit now though is a
necessary examination of ptsd
it also makes it feel just slightly
bloated
i know that sounds super disrespectful
to people who suffer from it but
just as a piece of film i felt like
those moments in iraq
derailed the film a bit now it is very
stylish in its direction
and the russo brothers were clearly
trying to make something memorable
however they do go a bit over the top
such as the butthole shot
and a lot of the time it feels like it's
mimicking other movies but
to less degrees of success i kind of got
a lot of good fellas vibes from it too
but whereas the characters in that had a
dark comedic side to them
cherry feels super depressing and bleak
so it's difficult to really feel like it
isn't exhausting at times
i'm guessing that they're gonna push for
oscars with this and whether you think
it deserves it or not
likely depends on whether you think
holland is right for the role
personally i liked him but i would have
liked to have seen more streamlining
going on in the film in order to narrow
down its runtime
in the end it's difficult to recommend
cherry to everyone for those who haven't
seen the bright and bubbly teen turning
to drug's story over a thousand times
before
we'll probably find something to enjoy
here and that's why it gets a 5.5 out of
10.
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the film so make sure you
comment below and let me know
if you want something else to watch then
check out our breakdown of why justice
league
sucks which is probably one of my
funnest videos
we went over the joss whedon film for
the last time before the snyder cut
releases
and it's just a nice trip down memory
lane reminding us how bad that movie
really was
without the way thank you for sticking
through the video i've been paul and
i'll see you next time
take care peace